this is Startalk Bancroft coming to us
from Earth mm-hmm okay dr. Tyson in your
opinion who would be the most
scientifically accurate and believable
superhero with superhuman abilities in
relation to real-world physics and
counterpoint the most unbelievable and
inaccurate and why yeah now the least
the least believable least believable
I'd say the Hulk the Hulk come on now is
that because he's made from gamma
radiation yeah so first of all gamma
rays can will will kill you okay but
let's hold that detail aside for the
moment all right now now next it would
mess with your DNA okay so we get that
so here he is turning green all right so
let's even allow that he increases in
mass and then decreases in mass like
weird is that if you if you want to do
that you converting energy into mass and
back again you he would explode wherever
he was the city whatever so you can't
just get bigger unless he has the same
mass and if he is then he's less dense
aha the state of Hulk than he is as
Bruce Banner so he's just kind of but he
be very kind of like marshmallow like
marshmallow me or like or or or or or
what's the balloon you play with it the
beat police punch wall you'd be like a
beach ball would be like a beach ball
right unless maybe that he could just
like 7-minute abs perhaps that's it that
could be the this is all the Hulk and
and and why is he so angry so much you
know that that's he's well no that's
anger management but see that's banners
repressed anger oh so it isn't
necessarily that the Hulk is is the
manna foundation right it's that he is
really banners the anger angry guy okay
he's the guy with the psychological
problems and then the Hulk
okay his so it's an extreme dr. Jekyll
and mr. Hyde absolutely but at least mr.
Hyde no yeah mr. Hyde didn't didn't have
more mass as in his state right he was
just changed psychologically right
so so I would say the Hulk with
everybody else you know there's some
plausible thing radioactive spider you
know okay I'm there you come from
another planet easy enough easy enough
don't have to explain rad and explain
right just like like that Saturday night
blitz live skip we're from France what
were they called the Coneheads opponent
we're from France and that was Eric's
point everybody everything everything
and who's the rock guy that's a little
weird the thing for the thing has a
little weird and who she is also like
the Hulk in that some weird
experimentation to write some into that
right right but then you change he has
to change some molecular lee but he
can't do that
see that's the coolest thing about the
thing he's just stuck like that nasty
rock look reminded me how he becomes
rock I forgot how yeah actually happened
but he got caught in this no no no I
know but in some kind of same radiation
thing right okay so so and now the
stretchy people but that's a little
weird
yes exactly you know yeah so that's
that's what's his face Plastic Man
Plastic Man yeah I Anna last oh man yeah
yeah yeah I don't know but still put the
Hulk at the top of the unbelievable list
he's unbelievable yeah but exactly was
the most believable for me yeah yeah
there you go
I'm with you on the Batman thing till I
think that's why he's able to beat
Superman it's because he has not been
establish it I think it has the movies
not out yet well but it's been done
before in the comic books and in an
animated series Batman wins and the
reason why he wins he's a job creator
he's a billionaire and that's the
brilliance the answer is a billionaire
okay you know this is Startalk